now it's all about stress-free cooking
cooking dishes in advance is a brilliant
way of taking the stress out of cooking
at home and many dishes just get better
and better with time
first up my amazing sticky pork ribs one
of the secrets to great cooking is
patience leaving dishes to marinade for
one or two days helps to develop the
flavor in your food and the end result
is so much more delicious it's a method
i use in the restaurants all the time
first off get your roasting tray put the
tray on the gas
pork ribs 60
meat and 35 40 fat give them a really
good season salt
and pepper
nice thing about this cut they stay
incredibly moist when they're on the
bone and the longer you cook them the
more delicious they become and just push
all that seasoning in to the pork
olive oil in
make sure that tray is nice and hot
and i really want that nice sort of
caramelization taking place on the pork
that's the nice thing about starting it
on top of the stove use your roasting
tray get them colored and then the oven
putting the ribs straight in the oven
you don't get the color it looks sort of
boiled as opposed to a nice caramelized
rib
ginger
you can't beat fresh ginger with sticky
pork ribs
place it down nice and firmly and slice
the thinner you slice the ginger
the more fragrant the ribs
garlic
and it's really important before you add
anything
to those ribs make sure we've got the
color from the ribs first don't rush it
turn them over
that's what i want
that nice crispy color
as they sort of
braise in the oven all that color just
turns into the most amazing flavor
braising is just a chef's turn for
cooking something slowly in liquid
right ginger and garlic in
spread it around on all those ribs to
sort of roast the ginger and the garlic
chili flakes
chili flakes in next szechuan pepper
citrusy vibrant peppercorns incredible
in
next staranese that gives it a really
nice sort of aniseedy flavour almost
like you're roasting the ribs in fennel
and
now we've got the heat
the spice
i want to sweeten things up a little bit
some fresh honey
honey glazes the pork beautifully
counteracts against all that spice in
there
but look what's happening the color on
the ribs is extraordinary it's like a
really nice chilli
sweet caramel now
soy sauce brings that little bit of sort
of saltiness to it
really generous with the soy sauce
japanese vinegar
two tablespoons of vinegar in
rice wine
it gives it that nice sort of um
tartness to the ribs
if you can't find rice wine our dry
sherry is a great substitute
300 ml
that takes out the heat of that szechuan
pepper those dry chili flakes make sure
they all lay down like a nice tight box
of matches bring that up to the boil
cooking is all about learning to develop
your own likes and dislikes so always
keep tasting to make sure you're happy
with a combination of flavors
it's lacking a little touch of vinegar
what that sharpness now think what's
going on the tartness the heat the
caramel the color on the ribs is amazing
i want a bit of a sort of oniony flavor
we'll put some spring in
whilst these ribs are in the oven the
spring onions will sort of puree but
give a sharpness to the final taste of
that pork
in with my spring onions
and with my stock
400 ml of stock
this is just a
simple chicken stock
the stock just sits underneath the ribs
it absorbs into the rib and the top of
the rib glazes
underneath the rib that gets crispy and
rich and that's what makes the ribs nice
and moist really important into the oven
cook at 180 for 30 minutes
then turn the ribs over and cook for a
further 30 minutes
now
wow
they smell incredible
each side has got that really nice
crispy roasted edge becomes sticky and
chewy and sweet sour the fats
disappeared and the pork just melts in
your mouth i want to take them to the
next level gas back on now
shake the tray
and this is the sort of
the way that we finish them in the
restaurant
but every minute
they glaze
in that tray they just get to taste
better and better
now look at them
i'm so happy with those
ribs done absolutely delicious now but
if you want you can put them in the
fridge and the flavor will keep
developing then just reheat them when
you want to serve
so
each rib has a nice slice of ginger on
there
wow look at that
delicious sticky ribs
with an amazing marinade
to make my food the tastiest it can be i
always start with the best ingredients i
can find
and the secret to getting the best is
simple
knowledge is crucial the more you know
about where your ingredients come from
and how they're produced the better so
ask lots of questions and learn
when it comes to buying pork you can't
do any better than ask a butcher and
award-winning master butcher danny
lidgate knows everything about the pig
from trotter to tail
this family have been in the meat
business for 150 years so this man
really is on the money
in comparison with other meats pork's
really good value you get some really
good cuts at really reasonable prices
and you can use everything from the tip
of the trotter down to the cheek we can
see here we've got the leg the leg is
about this region
really lean really good for things like
gammons and hams
coming down from the leg we've got the
loin and that's where the pork chops
come from if you take the bones out you
can bone and roll it and you end up with
a really nice easy to cook cylinder of
meat really easy to carve carve like a
loaf of bread
coming away from the loin we've got the
belly and you can see what belly is made
up of fatty parts and meaty parts don't
be scared of the amount of fat that's on
it you need that fat to give give the
flavors coming through
also make sure you can possibly buy it
with the skin on the skin will crispen
up nicely give you good crackling also
add flavor into the fat
lower down from the bellies we've got
the shoulders
really the shoulders are a great meat
they're slightly fattier than the rest
of the animal you can see with this pork
shoulder the amount of marbling you get
in the mussels the interior marbling
make sure you look for the marbling it's
essential for the flavor and it's going
to make a really good eating experience
with a pig there really is nothing to
waste the trousers even a really good
flavor because of their gelatinous
qualities and the meat can be really
really flavoursome also there's pigs
cheeks which obviously require a little
bit more cooking because of the use they
gets but the flavors you're gonna get
are gonna be completely different to any
other part of a pig
pork is an incredibly versatile meat
they say the only part you can't eat is
the oink
here's my guide to getting the best out
of familiar cuts
smoked or unsmoked bacon is not just for
breakfast it's brilliant transforming
salads gives a real depth of flavor to
stews and is delicious in quick and easy
pasta dishes
the leg joint best known for ham also
makes an inexpensive delicious sunday
roast and it's great served with peas
pudding
and the tenderloin fillet incredibly
lean healthy and fast to cook you can
stuff it cut it into scallops or strips
that are perfect for asian stir fries
[Music]
a calm kitchen is an efficient and
effective kitchen the less stressed you
are the better the food you'll produce
so whenever you can get ahead with your
cooking
here are three of my favorite recipes
that can be made beforehand and whose
flavour improves over time
[Music]
first up moroccan lamb with sweet potato
and raisin
[Music]
this super simple hassle-free recipe is
cooked all in one pot start by browning
chunks of lamb in hot olive oil
colour and remove
then fried onions
season
add chopped garlic
ground ginger and coriander
a teaspoon of whole cumin seeds
paprika and fennel seeds
a cinnamon stick bay leaf
and delicate strands of saffron
then fry to release all the aromatic
flavors
next add tomato puree
chunks of sweet potato and the juicy
brown lamb
for a sweet note add plump raisins
then cover with stock and simply leave
to simmer for a couple of hours
delicious eaten straight away but over
time the flavors will develop and
improve
when you're ready to serve simply finish
with fresh parsley
[Music]
minimal preparation and ready when you
want it fantastic moroccan lamb with
sweet potato and raisin
my next super simple dish that just gets
better and better with thyme is chili
chicken with ginger and coriander
[Music]
start by chopping chicken thighs into
pieces
now on with the marinade
chopped garlic
ginger
red chili
and lemon juice
[Music]
in a pan toast coriander and cumin seeds
to release their flavors grind and add
to the chicken
[Music]
then pour over plain yogurt
add turmeric and season
mix and leave to marinate from two hours
to overnight
next fry chopped onions in olive oil
then add chopped garlic and ginger
ground coriander garam masala
and turmeric
tomato puree and butter
next add the marinade chicken and all
the remaining marinade and cook until
tender
finally topped with coriander
marinated for flavor and cooked in 20
minutes chili chicken with ginger and
coriander a simple stress-free wonder
having a delicious sauce on hand to
serve with simply cooked fish or meat is
a brilliant stress buster my final
recipe is sweet pepper sauce with
grilled prawns
[Music]
for the sauce in hot olive oil
fry chopped garlic and diced bread
[Music]
then put them in a blender
[Music]
add chopped tomatoes
blister the skin of red peppers under a
hot grill intensifying the flavor
leave to cool then they're easy to peel
chop and add
blitz
add smoked paprika chili flakes and
roughly chopped almonds
a squeeze of lemon and a dash of sherry
vinegar
season
blitz again and add olive oil
[Music]
this sauce keeps really well in the
fridge and will intensify in flavor
i love it with simple king prawns
just add olive oil
and griddle for two minutes on each side
[Music]
sweet pepper sauce with grilled prawns
simply delicious
[Music]
made in advance ready when you want them
three stunning simple recipes that take
the stress out of the kitchen
five more of my 100 tips to make your
home cooking easier
kicking off with how to skin and de-bone
a fish the hassle-free way
this is basically a filleted side of
salmon it's been taken off the bone and
now
skin off pick up your knife a really
nice broad flexible
filleting knife
a little sharpen
lift up
the base of the towel and then just nick
a little bit at the end there twist the
knife almost as if it's horizontally
underneath the salmon pull
the skin and you slice
the salmon underneath and let the knife
do the work now get your skin
flip it back over
and check you're not leaving too much
salmon on top of the skin
pull it back
and nice and slowly get the skin wrap it
around your fingers
pull the salmon towards you and then
just all the way through
lay that down
one
nicely skinned salmon just like a
perfect snakeskin
get your knife and just run the knife
down
and then
with a pair of tweezers these are fish
tweezers but you can use normal tweezers
look for the head
up
and pull
and with the skin being removed from
underneath the salmon
the pin bones come out a lot easier
and the pinboards only go
to just basically halfway
along the fillet
one nice
fillet of salmon
beautiful
[Music]
there's still plenty of flavor in the
trimmings from affiliated fish my tip is
don't waste those fish bones add to
water wine a bay leaf and some chopped
veg to make a simple but versatile fish
talk at home the perfect base for a
delicious fish soup
[Music]
a great tip for intensely flavored
stress-free veg is to steam them in
their own juices simply add to a pan
with a knob of butter and seasoning then
cook on a low heat with a lid on to lock
in the moisture
[Music]
for crispy roast potatoes you can depend
on my tip is to parboil them leave them
to steam dry then sprinkle them with
semolina or flour and give them a good
roughing up this ensures they go really
crispy in the oven
a great tip for browning meat or fish is
to dry with kitchen roll before you cook
it then you'll get a much better color
too much moisture makes the meat steam
instead of sear and you'll lose that
rich brown crust like the one i got on
those sticky pork ribs
another secret to taking the stress out
of cooking is to anticipate the really
busy times when you'll need things to
hand that are already made
my next recipe can be kept on tap in the
fridge for weeks on end and is
guaranteed to liven up any quick meal
spicy chutney
with chutney standing by in the fridge
you can always add that special little
touch to a simple supper prove that
thinking ahead always pays off
pan on start toasting those spices keep
the pan nice and low cumin
very aromatic very fragrant and it's
almost like a light spice
next nice little coriander seeds
coriander in now you're going to get a
bit of heat in the chutney mustard seeds
well smaller than coriander seeds but so
much more powerful mustard seeds in
now curry leaves
they don't actually smell much dry but
the flavour they give off is
extraordinary curly's in
really important not to burn them
otherwise you'll
have that bitter taste
across the chutney keep the gas nice and
low the secret is sort of toasting them
so it releases that oil and intensifies
the spice touch of salt
and then a couple small powerful chilies
keep them whole
no one's going to eat them but it gives
that real nice burst of heat
now let them toast gently there we're
not going to chop the onion we're going
to grate it
why
because it sort of breaks down to a
really nice puree in the chutney when
you grate it hold the root in the palm
of your hand
and just push
nice long
grates
i want those nice long shards
look i've almost got a nice sort of
onion puree but it's nice and clear
a touch of olive oil
spices nicely toasted onions
[Music]
in three nice cloves of garlic slightly
crushed on
[Music]
lay it nice and flat and just slice the
garlic
nice thin slices
garlic in
taking your time to get the owners
caramelized beautifully will really reap
rewards in the long run
tamarind paste and sugar in with the
sugar first three nice tablespoons of
sugar
that will give a really nice syrup
effect
sort of nice rich syrupy texture
to the chutney
tamarind paste
you can get tamarind paste in most delis
and the big supermarkets
it's really nice thickening asian but it
gives that tartness the chutney and it's
sort of rich sugary spicy
next in with my coconut add four nice
tablespoons that'll give a nice body and
a really nice texture to the chutney
cook that coconut out and now add the
carrot
grated
the carrot just gives the chutney really
nice sort of crunch
but also helps to sort of cool down the
spice
carrots in
the water comes out the carrot flavors
the chutney beautifully but gives that
nice sort of vibrant bright color to it
as well
and grating it almost sort of it cooks
instantly but i want a bit of texture
through here
turn down the gas and just let that
simmer for five minutes
if the carrots aren't that moist and
juicy then put a couple of tablespoons
of water in there to help it along
now
just cook that out
for five minutes
just as those carrots start going nice
and soft don't overcook them you want
that nice texture in there slightly
spicy slightly sweet
gas off
keep those chilies in there for that
it's beautiful nice and gooey delicious
and
ready to go in his jar as that sits in
the fridge
just gets better and better and better
i love to eat this chutney with
cold meats or even cold fish but with
ham it's amazing
it's a really nice way of living up the
ham
just sort of roll it up
get a nice spoon
of chutney i mean it looks fantastic
chutney onto the plate
and serve and that is a
nice little
gem in the fridge that is worth prepping
in advance for
follow my ultimate cookery course
crammed with key lessons
top tips 100 recipes to stake your life
on and you'll literally be cooking
yourself into a better chef
many of these amazing recipes are on my
app please check out the app store for
details
go on get cooking
you